These are the chips powering
a transformational technology,
reshaping how we live,
work, and communicate.
They sit at the heart of a
new race between Washington
and Beijing.
The outcome will help determine
each superpower's status
in a changing world.
And right now, the most
advanced semiconductors
are designed by US companies.
They are also highly
sought after by China.
The chips that go into
training and running models
are the most complicated
things that humans make.
These are maybe the most
valuable goods in the world.
And US export controls are meant
to prevent their sale to China.
But a thriving market for
smuggled silicon has emerged.
The stakes are enormous.
China cares, both from a
technology point of view,
a business point of view, and
a political point of view.
We're going to show you how
this illegal trade works.
This guy is claiming
that he's just
taken stock of a big
load of H200's that's
come through Hong
Kong and is going
to be delivered to Shenzhen.
We will also reveal
how the controls are
tearing Chinese
and US technology
companies apart and forcing
Chinese chip makers to innovate.
It has also opened a new sphere
of competition between the two
superpowers.
But first, let's explain
what export controls are
and why they're being
used by Washington.
Why is China so desperate to
acquire US designated chips?
The reason is obvious.
AI is truly
transformative technology
and it's already changing how we
fight wars, run our government,
and operate companies.
It's essential for
the United States
to maintain a decisive
lead in the AI race.
In 2022, the US government
introduced blanket bans
on the sale of the most
advanced chips to China.
These chips were
invented in America.
Let's get that straight.
They were invented in America.
And we used to make 40%
of the world's chips.
Export controls were born in the
aftermath of the Second world
war, when the world was divided
along ideological lines.
The US and its
allies on one side,
the Soviet Union on the other.
Both sides were locked in a cold
war and a nuclear arms race.
Washington knew that
technological supremacy would
ensure military dominance.
So in 1949, it created
rules to stop Moscow
from obtaining critical
western technology.
But the fall of the Berlin Wall
and the dawn of the 21st century
created a new strategic rivalry,
this time between the US
and a rising China.
Many in Washington see Beijing
as a threat to the US-led world
order, and China's
AI development
as something that
must be curtailed.
It has turned to this
cold war era rule book
to stop its new rival.
Kevin Kurland spent 28 years
at the Department of Commerce.
Most advanced chips,
and certainly AI chips
that are designed
by US companies
and many western companies, are
virtually all fabbed or produced
in Taiwan, usually at TSMC.
And then those products
either get packaged in Taiwan
or in third countries.
And then from the
packagers they're
directed then to either send
the items back to the designer,
or many times they're
just directly sent
to an integrator, if you
will, or a distribution chain.
And so in order to harden
these supply chains,
you really need to have an
export compliance programme that
not only addresses the
activities that are happening,
for example, in
the United States,
but their distribution networks
and who their customers are.
In this tech war between
China and the US,
Taiwan plays a critical role.
The island has emerged
as an essential node
in the global
semiconductor supply chain.
That Beijing wants to
reunify with Taiwan has only
added to the geopolitical
significance of this story.
I've witnessed Taiwan's
growth into an AI powerhouse,
first as a student and
later as a reporter.
I've returned to Taipei to
attend Computex, the world's
most important chip conference.
What is on display here today
is the most leading edge
AI products, which are not
allowed for export in China.
These AI chips have become more
and more powerful, more and more
capable of training bigger
and more powerful AI models,
and the American government
has stopped Chinese companies
from getting their
hands on these chips.
So this is one of the racks that
go into the large data centre
product.
It's full of Nvidia
GPUs that are
essential for model training
and inference, i.e.,
the process of
running AI models.
And these chips are
among the series
that are restricted
for shipment to China.
Chris McGuire has advised
both the Biden and Trump
administrations on China
and emerging technologies.
Computing power is the
core input into AI.
It is the reason that training
and developing these models
is the most expensive thing
that humans are doing right now.
Nvidia is just the
example, frequently,
because they are so significant.
They are somewhere between 80%
to 90% of the AI chip market.
The reason for that
is that their products
are extremely good.
They're very, very good chips.
They're very, very powerful.
Nvidia has very, very robust
supply chains where they can
ensure, they can really maximise
their output and ensure delivery
on time to customers
as well as they can,
given the kind of supply
constraints that they have.
The world's most
valuable company
is now at the heart
of geopolitics.
The United States is
ahead in the AI race,
and we have to stay
ahead in the AI race.
So we've taken China
out of our forecast.
We're currently
shipping zero dollars.
Our market share has
gone from 95% to 0.
We're currently
assuming China is
going to be 0% of our business.
But winning the AI race has
become a priority for Beijing.
President Xi Jinping is
marshalling both the state
and private sectors to
catch up with the US.
The Chinese Ministry
of State Security
has recently said that
circumventing the US technology
blockade is one of
its top priorities.
It's certain that there are
diversion campaigns that
are being facilitated by the
Chinese intelligence services
in order to support their
technology companies.
This also is not surprising.
This is an asset that they
absolutely need to stay
competitive, that they
cannot make themselves.
And the only way that they can
actually remain competitive
is by either convincing the
United States to give it
to them, smuggling it,
or exploiting loopholes
in the export controls
that allow them to continue
to have access to them.
Without those things, there
would be a very significant drop
off for Chinese AI capabilities,
and I think the Chinese
government recognises that and
is pulling out all the stops
in order to prevent
that from happening.
Shares of Super Micro
Computer losing about a third
of their value.
It's because of an
international smuggling scandal.
In March this year, the
US Department of Justice
targeted employees at
Supermicro, a Taiwanese company
and Nvidia partner.
They stand accused of smuggling
$2.5bn worth of Nvidia chips
and servers into China.
The US alleges that
a front company
was used to divert the chips.
Supermicro was not named as
a defendant in the indictment
and has denied any wrongdoing,
as have the named defendants.
Still, analysts
say that the case
highlights historic failings
of the export control regime.
The smuggling really ranges from
mum and pop smuggling operations
to very large, systematic
criminal organisations.
Nvidia makes somewhere between
5mn and 10mn of these chips per
year.
If there's three or four
that go out in a backpack,
obviously you want to stop that.
But if you have organisations
that are funnelling tens
of thousands of chips,
that's a significant problem.
And I think that we've seen
organisations are committed
to that because this is an
extremely valuable industry.
So I've been reporting
on the various tactics
Chinese companies have used to
get their hands on American AI
chips for about four years now.
It's been an evolving
story, and these companies
have been using ever
more creative loopholes,
some legal, some illegal.
Last year we published
an investigation
that provided a snapshot into
how these large-scale chip
smuggling operations work.
We found a paper trail of
contracts and had discussions
with middlemen, and found
evidence of at least $1bn
of Nvidia GPUs being
brought into China.
The estimated number of chips
sold here on the black market
is far higher than that.
But really, this story
provided an insight
into how the larger-scale
operation works.
So I'm on Xiaohongshu here,
which is a Chinese social media
platform.
And if you type in
Nvidia or AMD you'll
come up with a lot of
these kinds of posts
by middlemen selling
these smuggled chips.
Here, we have H200s.
There's also someone
selling B300s,
which is a more
advanced Nvidia series.
And if you go onto
their profiles,
these guys are very clearly
advertising their sales.
This guy is claiming
that he's just
taken stock of a big
load of H200s that's
come through Hong
Kong and is going
to be delivered to Shenzhen.
Shenzhen is important
for the chip smuggling
story for a variety of different
reasons, the first of which
is it's a port city.
It's close to Hong
Kong, which is
a thoroughfare for a lot
of these smuggled chips.
It is also a place where
there's a lot of AI hardware.
So server builders,
rack builders.
It's somewhere where
the chips are just
being sold and repackaged
to the rest of China.
There are a lot of tech
salesmen based in Shenzhen.
It's a hardware hub in China.
And so if you've
got requirements
for new computers, new servers,
you go down to Shenzhen.
You speak to these
middlemen, and they will
create you a custom solution.
We are here at Huatung Bay in
Shenzhen, a famous electronics
market.
You can find any
electronics component here,
including lots of people
selling second-hand chips.
So we're going to go and see
if we can find anyone selling
Nvidia GPUs in here today.
The market is a labyrinth
of retailers selling
all kinds of
consumer electronics
and the components
that go into them.
I'm here to talk
with a chip reseller.
He's agreed to be interviewed,
but not on camera,
given the sensitivity
of the topic.
Until recently, it was also
possible to buy smuggled AI
chips from Nvidia and AMD.
But in recent months
it's become incredibly
difficult to get access to these
because the Chinese authorities
have restricted
imports of these chips
in order to support
local competitors.
That means that
the prices of these
have gone absolutely crazy.
We've spoken to a number of
sellers in this building,
and they said that prices
have gone absolutely crazy,
exacerbated also by the
memory chip shortage.
But for example, one seller
said that one B300 machine, that
is one of the leading
server machines,
has almost doubled in
price in recent months.
Chinese companies are
also exploiting loopholes
in the US export controls by
remotely accessing restricted
chips.
Right now, the
administration has not
articulated a coherent strategy
for controlling advanced compute
and AI chips.
The most advanced Nvidia chips,
say a Blackwell that is located
in a data centre in Malaysia,
there is no restriction on any
Chinese company from accessing
the compute power on that item.
So there's an
inconsistency there.
There's also a loophole in the
current regulations that do not
restrict a Chinese front
company in a third country,
or a Chinese-owned data
centre in a third country,
from buying the same chips or
servers that are restricted
for sale directly to China.
So on the one hand, you
have the Chinese AI labs
who want to build
the best models,
and it just so happens that
building the best model
means access to Nvidia GPUs.
But on the other hand, you also
have Chinese tech companies
that are trying to support the
growth of domestic AI chips,
like Huawei and Capricorn.
And their argument
is that we should
be supporting the growth
of these domestic chips.
And if that means relinquishing
some progress or lead on AI
in the short term, that's OK.
We should be doing it for the
long-term goal of Chinese AI
independence.
I don't buy that export
controls are driving China
to self-sufficiency.
They had already put
out a policy to do that.
To me, again,
export controls are
meant to maintain US leadership
by delaying their ability
to achieve the same goals,
or levels of innovation, that
allow the United States to
continue to be a leader,
both from an economic and a
national security perspective.
The question is,
ultimately, will China
be able to reach a level
where Huawei or one
of the other
Chinese AI companies
is equally or even better
than the American companies?
And I think that's still
a massive open question.
It looks like a no for now, but
China has proven time and time
again that it's very
capable of building
cutting-edge technology.
Right now, the US leads by
about eight months in AI.
That's per the latest
US government estimate.
It also means that AI is
doubling in capability
about every four months.
So an 8-month lead means about
a 4x capability difference.
That's significant, but
it's also not so significant
that I think the Chinese say,
OK, well we're down and out.
Right?
They're looking at this like, we
have an opportunity to catch up.
We're behind, but we think
we can close the gap.
We certainly have
become obsessed
with this idea of a time lag
between the US and China.
To me, I don't think it matters
a huge amount right now.
What certainly does
matter is whether or not
the US is the first to
build this fated future
of super general intelligence.
And if and when we
get to that stage,
it certainly looks
like America is
going to be the
first to get there,
given the trajectory of the
model development at the moment.
The United States just needs
to recognise that the US
and Chinese AI ecosystems
are fundamentally diverging.
That is exactly how it
was in the cold war.
The US and Soviet nuclear
programmes in no way helped each
other.
They were completely separate,
and that is undoubtedly
in the national security
interests of the United States.
That also did not preclude
co-operation between the United
States and the Soviet Union
on certain discrete areas
where we had shared interests.
And I think in AI we probably
need to think about co-operation
with China more in that sense.
For now, the US dominance
in AI hardware is clear.
There are several chokeholds
that Chinese companies have not
yet broken.
It will take time
and a lot of money
to build a rival ecosystem
to the one Nvidia
and its partners
have established.
But what we have
seen time and time
again is China build
technology that the world said
was outside of its grasp.
We know that Beijing
is pouring investment
into becoming a
self-sufficient AI state.
Can it succeed?
This is a story that will
define the world's future.